Okay.
Hey, what's going on It's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast and
ahhh
I'm just checking in on you
so you know your week's going.
How are you guys doing?
I am in a growth mode when
I'm in an awesome mood. Huh? You in a bad
mood. You're driving in your car there.
You're stuck in traffic. Is this
some dose in front of you? Huh?
Not doing what you want them to do.
Oh,
you having a little dictated thoughts?
Are you thinking about what you
would do if you were in power?
What you would do with this person?
What rule you would implement? You know,
it's gotta be awesome being a dictator.
You know what I mean?
How much fun is it on the 4th
of July to shoot off fireworks?
Can you imagine how much fun that fatty
over in North Korea is having? Okay.
You know how hard did they fucking laugh
when they shot that one over Japan?
Yeah,
I mean, Jesus Christ, man. How the fuck
did everybody had to go to bed after that?
Then he's just laying in bed,
so fucking amped up.
Like I can't believe we just did dead man.
It was crazy.
We just freaked out a whole country
calling each other up.
Do the whole world's talking about us,
man.
What a fucking lunatic.
What if there was a malfunction on
that fucking thing in any, you just,
it landed that guy.
I'm telling you man,
he's got to lay off the fucking sweet.
All that sugar is just sees there's
not fucking, it's not doing them good.
He's not making sound decisions.
Thank God we have such a
level headed guy or an arson.
Oh my God. Yeah. You know,
watching the dead zone was always scary.
Watching the Martin Sheen
character get into power,
but I think to go back and watch it now
is going to be just picture and Donald
Trump go on. The birds are away
gentlemen and doing that little thing.
He does what?
He puts his index finger and his thumb
together and this other three fingers are
in the air.
The birds of the way,
the greatest birds ever. Um, yeah.
Jesus Christ.
All this fucking ended day shit talking
about these goddamn tornadoes one after
another. You know, like some
battle royal of fucking weather.
I did Rogan's show last night.
There's nothing worse than hanging out
with somebody who's fucking informed.
He starts [inaudible] was
forming out over the Atlantic.
They'd never seen anything like this.
This is the size of fucking Florida.
Hey Bill,
how much time do you want to do tonight?
I was in a fucking panic. He was like
laughing at me. Go look at Bill's face.
Look at Bill's face. It's like, Yo, what
look am I supposed to have on my face?
When you basically said
you know everything,
you had everything but Jesus fucking
crowd surfing in on that fucking thing.
Not to mention I'm going to Mississippi
and Alabama this weekend. Okay.
Mesh the Yanno. Bam. The harder the FCC,
I'm going to tell you something right now
is a fucking northern white boy. Yanky.
I fucking love Mississippi and Alabama.
I love that whole fucking stretcher.
The south,
how they all shit on each other and then
it's somehow lands in Louisiana's lap,
right? You're in Georgia and all
they do is make fun, Alabama, right?
Alabama's like, Fuck Georgia. Hey,
at least we're not Mississippi.
And Mississippi is like, what
the fuck do you want from us? Oh,
why don't you go to Shreveport?
Tell me how you fucking enjoy that.
What you call over there, free
fair. And I cook no catfish. Um,
I love it down there.
Granted I'm fucking white.
You don't even have to claim
started marching, you know,
and I got all fucking nervous. I could
fake my way through it, you know,
give them a nod, you know,
slip into a store real quick.
Um, anyways, I don't know if I
mentioned this the other day. Um,
I started playing catch again. You know,
something I used to do as a kid. Good,
clean, fun. You just need a glove of
ball in a friend, maybe a baseball kid,
baseball kid, baseball year. Um,
and it's just been a good time.
This is how old I am.
I did 45 minutes a catio and
I guess I didn't stretch.
I thought I stretched and I went out
there and a oh Billy fucking old face.
Does not have the range of
motion he used to have. And, um,
my buddy through the ball and it bounced
in front of me and just sort of was
skidding along the ground
and I bent down to get it.
I anticipated it was going to hop.
I don't know what I was doing or I just
didn't get down far enough and went
right by my glove and hit right
in my left ghost white calf.
And,
um,
it only hurt as much as it
should or hurt like a baseball.
However fast it was traveling and hit the
ground, it's slowed down a little bit.
May then Nice Pete sound
against my Alabaster Shit.
Right then I thought I was fine.
And within like three throws,
my calf just fucking tightened up.
Like you couldn't believe.
And for like the last three days,
it's felt like it's on fire.
Right?
Like if you thought of my,
like if they were going to
do a documentary on my calf,
they would go to van Halen one,
and they would take that clip from
David Lee Roth singing, I'm on fire.
Um, it's been fucking killing
me. So, uh, I got to have a,
I don't know, not going to have
somebody fucking work it out, but, uh,
my buddy gave me this shit.
This is a free advertisement.
This is how fucking good these
guys are. It's called, uh,
Arna Care Gel. They ever heard of
this stuff? It's, it's homeopathic.
What'd you call me?
Homeopathic medicine aren't a care,
it's for muscle pain and stiffness,
swelling from injuries and bruising.
I get pain relief. This shit, I'm
telling you, it's fucking magic.
I put this stuff on, I felt like
I was bionic, you know, like,
like in that you could fix me
like a machine. One of those,
one of those fucking Moonraker movies,
blade runner, whatever the fuck it is.
Like they would just open my calf and it
looked like the inside of a fucking mix
. Uh, I just felt like that they just,
that think just cited a couple of wires,
wires together. I mean,
it didn't cure me. I mean,
it definitely feel like now I just feel
like I got hit with a golf ball rather
than a baseball.
MMM.
You know at the end of a drive,
I'm not saying right off the tee,
let's not get crazy hurricanes thinking
crazy. So anyways, that's the free thing.
I'll tell you right now,
if you fucking ever do something before
you go to them as suits and having
fucking unglue your
muscles and get all that,
what's out of there as my a person says,
ah,
Arna cared gel a r.
N I care Arnie care like Arnold
Palmer except it's I a r n.
I. O. N e. S. H. A. R. N. I.
E. Right here. Why don't you
confuse the people. See goes,
I had to do with something free massage
because I lost another advertiser.
I can't believe it. I put my fucking
heart and soul into these fucking reads.
You know I could go monotone.
Yeah,
I can just read what they wrote.
I could just go with they've won.
Okay,
but you're not going to listen.
And I know this
show must go on even if I'm
reading fucking advertising,
but those fucking console over there.
Okay.
The most suits people.
That was a one and done.
How dare you bring up hand jobs that at
the end of the, uh, the massage rates,
what the fuck are you talking about?
That's a huge part of your industry.
Yeah.
Either you're doing it,
oh, you're not doing it
the fuck.
It's like you're, you're in food.
You're selling some sort of food.
Now bring up trans fat.
Like that's not a big fucking issue.
That is a hot button issue.
That debt is debt that needs to be
brought up in front of Congress. When I,
I stand by that.
Yeah.
If you can legalize weed at a state level,
you should be able to legalize a hand
job at the state level. Okay. Now,
if the feds come in and she's got your
Dick in her hand, you're on. You're wrong.
All right. You're on your fucking own.
You're Joe Pesci and good fellas out. No.
Right.
That's it.
Okay.
That's it. All right ladies.
It does it mean anything to
us. Doesn't mean anything.
If you ever saw the look on the woman's
face when she's doing it. I mean,
I swear to God, I swear to God,
like it's just like she, she,
I don't know what she did.
Thinking fucking zillion other things.
Yeah.
Which is probably usually where you got
this part of your safe place, you know,
when you're fucking employed in
the sex industry. Um, no. Well,
I don't know what the fuck to tell you.
I don't know what to tell you.
So because I brought that up, which
was funny enough to make people listen,
they walked away from all the fucking
massages that my listeners would have got.
Yeah.
No, I'm not. Galatia of them
would have been expecting
some sort of a hand release at the end
of it. So maybe, maybe that's okay.
I'll take that. Okay. I will
take that part of it. All right.
When I'm getting tired of
these deeds, deeds of the
blue aprons, the nature boxes,
you know,
they're all good when the sun's out in
the second they see a little bit of rough
water.
Yeah.
What do they do? They
fucking pull up stakes. Those
fucking phony bastards. Okay.
And they take their aprons
and they fucking twats and
they go to somebody else's
podcast. And I'll tell you right
now, I've had enough of it.
Okay.
Do My,
my gosh darn just over here to try and
put a little bit of money in your pocket.
You know, how many people do you
think at that fucking massage place?
I've actually gone to a massage
parlor and gotten fucking jerked off.
How many do you know what I mean?
Fucking out.
She's done. Don't get me fucking
started. You know, I got in the, uh,
all my dogs back in town.
Oh Cleo,
this is back in town. I just saw
her, she fucking freaked out.
We had a nice little battle.
Royal took over this awesome fucking hike.
Love that Goddamn dog. And I love
that. She's got a great family now.
Family babies. And uh, she put
her on a little bit of weight.
He's new people. They're, they're
uh, they're treating her right. Um,
but she looked awesome and, uh, same
old dog dragged me down the street,
all frigging excited and that
type of stuff. So, uh, it's out.
It all worked out nice,
happy.
And then she got a little more white
whiskers around her muzzle, you know,
becoming very distinguished and stately.
These last couple of a bump in a less, I
don't know, gave away almost a year ago.
Fucking unbelievable. Nine months
ago, 10 months ago, nine months ago,
nine months ago. Um, so it was great
to see her and everything. So, uh,
she's in town for like 10 days. Uh,
I'm leaving for a couple of days,
but that's what I do when she comes to
town and take for a hike every morning.
It's kind of been working out. I get to
see her every couple of months, you know,
she's not around where she can eat
my baby or attack somebody else,
so she'll never get put down and I
won't have to deal with an unbelievable
amount of guilty. And she's got a
great house and she's, you know,
she's fattened up. It's fucking perfect.
I love it. She's not fat people.
I'm just saying she is living a good
life, full of energy. Still a ball.
A muscle though. Good Lord.
That's a strong dog. Um,
I still miss the hell out of her,
but I definitely made the right decision.
So anyways, um, what's going on tonight?
All the Patriots yet
that dad, Buddha, Buddha,
[inaudible] and ignore your fucking wife.
Football season is back bay.
Ignore the arcade.
Sorry. Just blow out years. Ignore the
hurricanes. Ignore all fatty up there.
Fucking doesn't it fucking
guy in North Korea.
Did he look like he's the same shape
is like curly from the fucking three
stooges? You know, I'd love to see
me. They just the old football sketch,
you know,
can somebody please do that just for a
sort of photoshopping we'll do in that
thing. Does that run in, in placing
all Rah rob doing that whole thing.
Just put his head on Curley's
fucking body. It's what he's,
he's Kim Jong Howard.
Uh, how many times would I be put
to death in that fucking country?
I can't even fucking imagine.
I can't even imagine. You know,
you gotta go up swinging. You
got to go out like a fucking,
you know, Gino, I'm not,
I, you know, sit down
was fucking brutal guy.
But did you see how that guy went out?
He was standing there.
He's just stare at them all in the eye.
They put the rope around his neck.
He's still talking shit. Yeah. Go
Fuck Yourself. Go Fuck Yourself.
You know it's fucking any people always
talk about do it. When you in Philly,
how did you handle that? Fucked and
wiggled a little sit down. Handled.
He was talking shit. Right? Until
they fucking Yank that rope. Oh,
that lever or whatever. Oh Man. Crying
like a little girl. Go on. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. Sweep the streets.
Anything you want. Yeah,
yeah. That's how I would've gone out.
Gone into the next world and God,
what did you spend looking at
me shaking his head, you know,
of all the awful fucking things you did.
I think you're bitchy way.
You left was the worst.
Get out of my sight and then they just
pushes the button and go down to health.
I go down a hill and I burn forever.
And that's a good fucking thing to bring
up. When you got two gigs coming up,
Mississippi and Alabama, I'm
gonna tell you, go down. May Cbl,
bamboulas mother fuckers ain't got
computers yet. They ain't got computers.
I'll tell you, they still eat. They'll
still lead. And I don't tell you,
give him some clothes line. They'll
catch catfish and dry your overalls,
mother fuckers,
they can live off the land.
You know, if, uh, what Rogan was
telling me was even remotely true. Um,
him and Jimmy Dore are the
two most informed fucking
comedians I know as far as
they actually pay attention to shit.
Somebody says some shit.
And rather than just taking it as truth,
they actually will fucking research it.
They'll have guests on their
show. I cannot recommend
their podcasts. And G, uh,
his by Joe's podcast
in a, um, Jimmy doors,
youtube show highly enough, and you don't
always have to fucking agree with them,
but I'll tell you right now,
I want to tell you something right
now if you fucking watch and see.
And then if you're watching Fox News
and Shit, I mean, that's, you know,
those people. Okay, I'm going to, you
know, no offense to other comedians,
but they're definitely more well
spoken than a lot of us. But, you know,
I'm just saying there is
a whole, uh, you know,
just look at how they read
the ads on those channels
and then, you know, exactly,
like they're, they're, they're,
they're stuck between the lines.
I don't know what I'm talking about. Um,
uh, fuck that reminded me of something.
I just forgot it. What the hell was
it? Something I wanted to talk about.
Not News,
not be in between the lines.
Ah, fuck it. It's over. Um,
so anyways, I am going to, uh,
one of my favorite things
and I don't have a lot of,
I don't have any favorite
things in Mississippi yet
because I've only been there
one time,
two times.
One time I was driving up to the airport
after I watched the Patriots beat the
rams and the Superbowl and I just couldn't
get a flight into fucking New Orleans.
So we drove, we flew in and out of
fucking, uh, what does it, Baton Rouge,
Mississippi. I'm kidding.
Um, Jackson, Jackson,
Mississippi. And um, and then I
did a gig there a few years ago.
Um, so, ah, I don't know a
lot about it, but Alabama,
Alabama, I'll taste him. What I love about
Alabama, I love the, uh, first of all,
the fucking, I'm going to the Alabama
game, by the way, on Saturday.
Hello?
It's an afternoon game against
mighty mighty Fresno state.
They can surprise some people.
MMM.
So I'm going to go there. I'm not going
to be a con and root against Alabama.
I really don't hate the crimson tide.
It's just that they are the fucking,
the Yankees or the Patriots,
so f of fleeing on,
they're the ones that always fucking,
you know, uh, winning, right. So, uh,
we'll Yankees,
you know,
they've won enough even though
they haven't won since 2009, two.
There's still the fucking Yankee
sitting on 27. You know what I mean?
MMM.
I just couldn't become a college
fan and jump on that bandwagon.
Like if I was watching the NFL, I would
fucking root against the Patriots to,
that's what you do with you. If you
just what you do, it's what you do.
You don't just jump on the fucking big
bandwagon. I'm like, Roger Clemens.
When he joined the Yankees after
they'd already one fucking three.
MMM.
I would say,
yeah,
yeah. That's, that's how, that's why I
root against them. So when I go there,
I'm not going to be a cop.
I'm going to root for Alabama,
but there's a major part of me that wants
to bet Fresno state and just start the
game up. Like, you know,
it's 57 to nothing,
but you know what it is.
Nick Saban has an intensity slash anger.
Slash inability.
I'm telling you to drown a puppy that I,
I just know that even as second string,
it's just going to keep, you know,
running up the points because they
don't want to deal with it in practice.
You know that they didn't score another
fucking 30 points against Fresno's
number one,
I don't know anything about Fresno state.
I'm not trying to disrespect Fresno.
Okay.
Now if you like me and you watch any
sort of basic cable stuff about gangs or
prisons or anything, they
always, it's, you know,
the second they start one of those shows,
you can literally turn over an hour.
Glass is sand and it's not getting maybe
at halfway through before they ended up
in Fresno. And then there's
always that guy, you know,
with the Bandana all the way up to
under resides Bay Bandana on his head.
And then the dark sunglasses,
they have his voice altered named Burton
or burden care. But you're aware of
[inaudible] you can understand where
they're saying right. I'll talk to him.
[inaudible] not good. My
Eric's would call. Um,
so I'm not trying to fuck with Fresno.
All right.
Everybody knows that fucking stretch
between La and San Francisco.
You don't know what the
fuck goes on out there.
Charlie Manson lived somewhere up there.
All right. There's a nice national park.
There's a bunch of people growing
food. But other than that, you know,
I don't know what goes on other than it's
really hot and a lot of people grew up
career board mirror.
So I don't have any fun,
not trying to fucking shit on Fresno.
Okay.
I'm just a praise pasty freckled guy
trying to go to a football game. So I'm,
I'm working with del Rey and fucking Joe
Botnick, the Rosebowl tailgate legend.
And A,
we're doing a Gig at some casino in a
missed ship and then were in Alabama.
And when I go down, Bam, I got placed.
I liked to eat every time I go there,
first time I went there,
a fan came. Remember how I
found out by bond gold. EBAC,
time saws.
Barbecue started stands
for smart ass Wilson's.
I always go there.
They have a Manet's based barbecue sauce.
Swear to God. It's white. You like,
there's no way that's going to taste good.
You eat it. You like
Jesus. Fucking delicious.
Jesus Christ. Is that delicious?
So, um, that's a good time. Um,
I'm actually thinking of
coming back again next year.
I'm going to do quick kick here and then
think I'm going to come back next year.
Do a little bit of a bigger show
and next GM and go to Talladega.
I went to Daytona 500. I'm going to go
Talladega next. I gotta go to that man.
I used to always watch that with hair
game in a scold main car. Cale Yarborough.
I'm fucking, uh, what's
his fate? Rusty Wallace.
Daryl hawala trip.
Who else was fucking running back then?
Richard Petty was winded.
Now I told you I used to buy
all the fucking model cars.
I'd build them and put the
stickers on them and shit.
I used to always skip the engine because
they just wanted to get to the fucking
car part and I wouldn't let it dry
and I wouldn't let the paint dry.
I was just too fucking,
they always came out like shit.
That was glue all over the place because
I've just too impatient, you know?
I wish I could buy one of those models
again and actually just take the time to
see if I could do it right.
Like the people who really did it right.
They would paint all the parts before
they even took it off that plastic grid
and they would let it dry for like a day
and then they would just slowly put the
whole fucking thing together and
it was a fucking work of that.
I would never do that.
I was all, you know,
you know as the worst was when you'd
remember the decals and he'd soak them in
the warm water, then they'd all start
coming off and you were like fuck.
And they would roll up
and all look like shit.
They'd be put on lead like
an angle, you know? Then you,
then you had like the older guys,
right?
And they had a little thing
like parent tweezers, all right,
they'd have a pair of tweezers
and that little fucking, you know,
Julie or glasses on and they
put it on and look unbelievable.
And I always wish I had the
patience to do that and I don't.
And that's why stand up comedy has been
the only thing that I was ever good at
is because it is just going up there
and just fucking letting you add go.
And I kind of learned something this
week within in a frustrating way,
trying to learn drums. And it's just
like to do, you have to fucking sit down.
And if you want to learn something,
you have to take a big breath.
You have to relax and you
have to start really slow.
And I've known this for fucking years.
I've seen everybody talk about it.
Some of the most monster players ever
talk about how slow they start a new idea.
But the whole thing is, you know, with
all this information on the Internet,
you can be like, well, what bpms is this
song? It's 115 and then you just thinking,
I can get it you,
you 10 feet.
And so you start playing it like
95 when you should be like 65.
So that's my new shit.
I got to fucking relax.
I got to pick like one or two things
and just stick with that for a while,
just like you would with the model,
right? Just leave those pieces on there.
Paint the fucking thing and walk away.
Just let it dry. So, um, anyways,
I know I'm a fucking mess here. I'm all
over. I'm all over the Goddamn map. Uh,
22 minutes of fucking talking shit. All
right, we've got six reads here. People,
you know, these fucking reads
like these, these advertisers,
this is becoming like a
special forces, you know, or,
or a fucking some sort of military
operation here. It's like, you know,
most of you will. All right, um,
private pile infantry. You're made
it all right. Draft kings, everybody.
Oh,
is this the perfect read for tonight or
what fantasy football season is finally
fucking,
and there's no better way to get closer
to the game you love with draft kings.
One week fantasy fucking
football draft kings is hosting a
$100,000 or 50 grand after
taxes contest this Sunday.
That is totally free.
Free, free, free to enter.
And if you draft the perfect lineup,
you can win $1 billion.
In other words, the odds of you doing
that as fucking, you know, I dunno,
it's pretty fucking difficult.
It's,
the odds of them have actually taken your
junk and make it into a perfect pussy.
You know, we're not there yet. Okay.
But it doesn't stop these brave fucking
people from still trying with draft
kings.
There are many ways to play choose between
public contexts with big cash prizes
or private context tests where you can
compete against a group of your friends.
Draftkings also has the beginner and
casual content contests where you can,
where you'll play against people.
I have to get glasses. Well,
you'll play against people of a
similar skill level. Everybody gets,
the best part is you get to draft a new
team each week without any commitment.
Where is this going?
Nowhere Bitch.
So to get draft kings.com now
and use Promo Code Burn, uh,
use program promocode bird to play in the
draft kings free contest with $100,000
in total prizes this Sunday.
And if you draft the perfect lineup,
you can win $1 billion, $1
billion. Do you realize that?
What that is? Do you have an
that's, that's enough to buy?
Like,
I dunno,
I would say like $706 million mans.
You could make 700 Steve Austin's and
still have some money left over to put on
a gift certificate. A use my promo
code bird, a play for free this Sunday.
That's Promo Code burpee.
You are
are@draftkings.com eligibility
restrictions apply.
See draft kings.com for details.
Eligibility restriction.
That means their own employees probably
can't play, I would think. All right.
Oh Shit. Look, I'll snap.
Look who's back. Oh,
club looking good.
Doesn't have to cost a fortune.
Fan Club is revolutionizing the
way men shop at five o' clock.
Geez, I've never had found a thing that
says their name more than these people.
They found a way to make great looking
clothes affordable for everyone who
Faffel clip.
Also understands that your
time is extremely valuable.
Why wasted at the mall or wandering
around in the stores each month?
They send you a curated,
but everybody curates now curated box of
two to three items that are handpicked
from the finest vine of short trees to
match the current season and your style.
What's their name again?
Partners with cutting
edge designers and brands,
so you'll get the same quality as
top designer clothes for way less.
They've been helping men with fashion
for over 15 years and shipped to over
$100,000 100,000 men every month.
Chris Paul and Mark Walberg Cues,
five o' clock in five
photo is featured in Gq,
vice and instyle. Among
other publications. They
know what they're doing.
So if you don't, that's okay. Why?
Because Oh club will help you build
your wardrobe one month at a time.
Jesus Christ. I mean more times
are you going to say their name?
You get a hundred attorney dollars
worth of clothes for just $60 a month.
You can pause or cancel any time. No
commitments. I said, no way. A bitch.
And as a fan club member,
five four club baby member,
you'll also receive up to 50% off items
in their shop and access to exclusive
members only, not the jacket items.
Free shipping and size exchanges.
Go to first.
Bye.
[inaudible]
oh club
a.com right now and enter Promo code Burt,
and they'll give you 50% off your first
month's package plus a free pair of
sunglasses.
Everything is so much crisper and clearer.
That's 50% off your first
package at five four club,
spelled F as in Fab. I as an Av, v, e foe,
F, O, u. R,
the number's five four club.com C L U
b.com Promo Code birth five four club.com
Promo Code Burger. That's it. All right.
Oh, lift everybody. Oh Jesus Christ.
Look who's back. It's Lyft.
You don't want to lift. Knows.
They know that their drivers are
what keeps them moving. Well,
that's what the fuck you do.
Okay.
Do you know what Koch knows
if you're thirsty,
so they do everything they could do to
make sure their drivers are happy on
every trip.
Lyft is the ride sharing company that
believes in treating its people better.
Lift believes that being a ride share
drivers should be fun if you're having a
good time.
So are their passengers.
If you're choosing a ride
sharing company to drive for,
go with the company
that treats you better.
Lift lift was the first to offer in APP,
uh,
tipping. When you drive for
Lyft, you keep 100% of the tips.
Drivers get paid over $200 million in
tips. Since the feature was introduced,
express pay lets drivers get paid
almost instantly instead of four weeks.
Lyft has even taken the
guesswork out of pickups.
The new amp amp device uses isn't that
APP color coding to help passengers find
their drivers. You can earn hundreds
of dollars a week plus tips. One,
earn more money, drive more. It's never
been easy to give yourself a raise.
It's a simple formula.
Happy drivers mean happy passengers.
Maybe that's why nine out
of 10 on Lyft riders, uh,
get a perfect five star rating.
So joined the ride sharing company that
believes in treating his people better.
Go to
lift.com/bird today and you'll get
a $500 new driver bonus. That's
left.com/bar lift.com/burr and
limited time only terms apply.
Is that the new thing you say
you fucking named 50 time.
Oh,
this is the classic. This is the
stairway to heaven of my advertising.
Look who's back.
It's old zip.
Talk about the challenge of finding
great talent and or the importance of
finding great talent to a successful
business. I'll tell you right now,
finding town is easy, but to find
great channel wall, that's really hard,
especially if you want to be
successful in business. I'm bill burn.
I approve this message.
How Zip?
It's different with
Ziprecruiter Gouda.
You can post your job to 100 plus job
sites with just one click. It's so easy.
Then their powerful technology weight
efficiently matches the right people to
your job better than anyone else.
That's why zip
is different. Unlike other job sites. Zip
does it depend on candidates finding you.
It's, it's fine. It finds them. In fact,
80% of employers who post
a job on ZipRecruiter get
a quality candidate through
the site within one day. No more juggling
emails or calls to your fucking office.
Simply screen rate and manage
candidates in wall in one place with
Ziprecruiter's.
Easy to use dashboard.
Find out today why zip?
Yeah.
Recruiter has been used by businesses
of all sizes to find the most qualified
job candidates and immediate results,
and right now my listeners plus any other
fucking podcast they advertise on can
post jobs on Ziprecruiter
for free. That's right. Free.
Just go to ziprecruiter.com/bar that's
ziprecruiter.com/pat one more time to try
to try it for free.
Go to zip
[inaudible] dot com slash
[inaudible] all right,
upside upside.com boy,
you turned me inside out
and go fuck yourself.
There's a better way for you to buy
business travel. It's called up sad dam.
No upside. Dot commy turned me.
Somebody finally told me how to sing,
that every time you buy a trip on upside
upside.com to turn on me,
you'll save your company a ton of money
and they give you an Amazon gift card
worth hundreds of dollars.
Upsides able to do this
because they bundle your
flights and hotels together for
one low price bundling prices saves money.
It's like having a threesome.
It saves condom. What it
is, that's still faith.
It is for me.
If you're a frequent business travel,
your company saves a ton of money and
you could get thousands a year in gift
cards just for buying your air and
hotel together@upside.com plus,
you'll still get all your miles.
If you're shopping for business travel.
You'd be crazy not to checkout upside.com
it takes just three minutes to see how
much you can save by buying your flights
and hotels together for one low price.
And right now when you use my neighbor,
you're guaranteed to get at
least a $100 Amazon gift card.
Your your first trip. That's my
name. [inaudible], B u, R, r. Uh,
to get
at least a $100 Amazon Gift Card for free,
save big on travel and get
a big gift card every trip.
Evidently I love upside dot.
Boy,
you turned me upside.com you're
turning me minimum purchase required.
See Site for complete details. Um, hey.
You know what I watched the other day,
I watched an episode at Tj fucking hookah.
The,
I will tell you this right now,
the funniest running you will ever see
in your life by William Shatner and his
fucking partner. Um, all
they do is their concert.
They always have like a fucking wide
shot and they show TJ hooker running like
he runs for like six seconds every
shot. It's like, why? I would,
you know what it is,
is they had it,
they had to fucking do an hours 22 or I
forget what a full season was back then.
I'm only 22 episodes of an hour long show.
That's 22 hours of television
will actually with the, uh,
what the commercials, eight minutes per
half hour, 44 minutes they had right.
44 minutes of fucking Shit Times 22.
I mean, it's, it's like
where we came up short again.
We'll just have William
Shatner run a little longer.
Can TJ hooker like run half the length
of a football field before he catches up
to somebody a third of his fucking age?
I saw the one, uh, I gotta
get this actress name.
Um, he was one, he was one of my, uh,
one of my favorite actors when I
was growing up. He was in colors.
He was a Latino duty, got hit by a drunk
driver, unfortunately was like 37 or 30,
38 years old. Hang on, I gotta get
this guy's name. Ah, let's see. Colors.
I am DB. I didn't know Don
Cheadle was in that movie.
I got to watch that again.
That'd be one of his earliest ones.
I am a nightmare walking. Um,
it's something silver, I believe.
Trinidad Silva. So he was
in this episode of, um,
this episode of,
uh,
Tj hooker and it was fucking hilarious
because all of a sudden TJ hooker when
he's talking to them would throw in some
fucking Latino words and it was only
like shit that like a let white
people know, like cake pasta,
fucking Agua. He said at one point, well
maybe if you stop back to like a polo,
like he, he threw in like
chicken and it's just like, yeah,
that's because the writing staff
ordered El Polo local that day.
But Trinidad silver, I believe
he was in the jerk. Um,
I think he was in the, Oh, you know
what, when I look up this fucking,
this guy was amazing.
He was in Hill street blues.
He was in the jerk.
Yeah.
He actually died during the filming of
a underrated movie by Weird Al Yankovic
called UHF. I was in colors. Uh, yeah.
Hill street blues stir crazy.
He had such shame.
He died so young yet he was on Barney
Miller. I mean that this Gulu grant,
the white shadow, the jerk,
this guys imdv page Beretta.
You know, granted you played, played a
perp in all of those fucking things here.
He's probably fixing games in the white
shadow. That's the way it was back then.
And this guy somehow got through it
and open the doors for a bunch of other
people. I hadn't seen him in a
while. It was great to see him.
Trinidad silver look 'em up. Uh,
1950 to 1988. Unfortunately he was,
uh, he was only 38 years
old. Jesus Christ. Um,
phenomenal actor though. Alright.
Legal Zoom. Last one here. Legal Zoom.
When you run your own business,
when you know that time equals money,
it's not just an old saying,
it's a fact. So why Hawaii?
Her waste your valuable time dealing with
an issue that legal zoom can help you
with. I'm doing this because I'm going
to Mississippi and Alabama this weekend.
You may already know, put your hands in
the air and feel the spirit of Jesus.
They had over 2 million people have
used legal zoom to start their business,
but legal zoom services don't end there.
There's a kingdom waiting
for you after your kit.
They're fucking website run in a
business comes with taxes, contracts,
hiring employees,
and the devil basically a lot of
fine print and we all know that.
The devil's in the details.
I'm sorry.
That's why legal zone built a network
of independent attorneys licensed in all
50 states, not in Puerto
Rico, not in our territories,
just the 50 states they can provide the
advice you need to get through the daily
grind of running your business. By
the way, everybody in Puerto Rico,
I hope you make it through this storm.
Good Lord.
Good Lord, man. Okay,
Rogan. Scared the shit out of
me and I live in fucking la.
I can't imagine what this poor
people doing out there. Uh,
and you don't have to worry about billable
hours since legal zoom is in a law
firm. Instead you can count on
upfront pricing and clarity.
Call to action and invest your time and
money and growing your business and let
legals, he'll help you out with
legal stuff. For special savings,
be for special savings.
Be sure to enter Promo Code burpee.
You are in the referral box at checkout.
That's Promo Code Burger
for special savings
only@legalzoomdotcomhilegalzoom.com
all right,
I think that's the podcast for this week.
I'm going to go play some drums and he
barely relaxed. No, actually I'm not.
I gotta go write an episode.
Episode 309
of a
season three of f is for
family were actually this week.
We're working on a episode seven
so you not in the business.
The reason why it's called three
Oh nine three means season three.
I never knew what that meant. I finally
figured it out after three seasons.
I remember last year,
it's like we're working on two oh four,
and I'd be sitting in the back of the
room, like we're not on the 204th episode.
But I knew that sounded
stupid. So I finally just, I
finally just asked, you know,
and I felt it.
I felt all the rangers looking at me like,
why is this hacky comedian in this
fucking room? You know, when it hurts,
I'm not kidding. My work with great
people in case any of them are listening.
And if you're the one person in
the writers from listening to your,
my favorite writer, the Bro, um,
so I'm writing the episode three Oh nine.
That's why I have to do today.
I just do like,
I do two scenes a day and
then I get through the script
and then I do like three
or four passes. I didn't do that last
year, but this year I'm going to do it.
And then, uh, I bring it in and
then everybody just guts the thing.
And maybe like three jokes make it,
but you know,
it's all about making that template.
And that's the game that everybody
fucking place. All right,
so that's the podcast.
Let's go pats
Dr fucking year off.
Right?
Who's going to step into Edelman shoes
before he comes back for the wonderful
playoff run? Okay. I hope it doesn't
come back too soon. You know?
Do you know why Edelman got hurt?
That was the curse of the
nude ESPN magazine issue.
You know what I mean?
I,
I can't remember the last time I laughed
harder than watching him jump through
the air, catch a ball and have it over
his junk. Is he through through the year?
That was one of the funniest
fucking things I've ever seen.
I just don't understand how a woman,
I don't know, maybe I guess what,
I just don't understand
how any level that is.
Anything other than fucking hilarious
naked men are for,
they were just funny.
I used to do a bit,
my accident and naked
man is one of two things.
It's either funny or scary
depending on what's happening.
Like if you're at a game and a naked
guy runs across the fucking field,
I mean you're fucking on the
ground laughing. However,
if you're walking home late at night and
a naked guy jumps out of Bush, like, ah,
that's the scariest fucking
thing you'll ever see, right.
I'd rather see a fucking rattlesnake,
you know,
I would rather see that and I'm
terrified of fucking snakes. Okay.
Then to have some fucking naked
jump out of a fucking Bush. Um,
I probably shouldn't just giving out
that information. All right. Anyways,
do let's troll them.
Um, anyways. All right.
That's the a the podcast for a this
Thursday. I have a great weekend.
You can't enjoy the football game tonight.
That college football this weekend.
Maybe tune into Alabama, Fresno
state. I will be there. I'll be there.
And a thank you to everybody
in Mississippi and Alabama
for a buying the tickets.
I'm going to come out there
with my Yankee Bullshit and uh,
telling you guys once again why
you lost that war. Uh, all right.
Enjoy the,
uh,
the music here and we're going to have
another half hour stuff from a classic
podcast from a Thursday gone by in a
year that already happened or possibly
early this year. I don't
know what it is. All right.
That's
[inaudible].
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
hey,
what's going on?
It's built bar and this is the
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
September 7th,
2009.
Happy Labor Day.
What are you guys doing today? Huh?
With your big bad days off? Uh,
what are you doing? You're laying
around you becoming fat fucks.
What are you doing when you barbecue?
When we're going over to Carol's
and we're going to have a barbecue.
Do you want to come Steven? No, I don't.
I want to fucking drink and
forget that I married you, Carol.
I'm sorry. I'm going to fuck. I'm
moving some shit around right now.
This is the Monday morning caught podcast.
Almost said cod past podcasts.
I'm actually gonna try to do some,
uh,
something different this week because
it's such a special fucking holiday cause
it is Labor Day.
Why do they go Lou [inaudible] I'm sorry.
I always have to do a tribute
to fucking eighties comedy.
I'm actually watching a fucking, I watch
too much sports this weekend and I just,
uh, I was watching the end of the Colorado
Colorado state football game and right
after it, um, I take best
damn tough man, you know,
cause it game always goes
longer than its allotted,
so you have to take the next show,
listen to this fucking spares.
He goes by the name of the coach.
This is the classic example of a scared
guy before a fight and he's trying to
turn that fear into like
some sort of fucking, uh,
courage. But it works. This guy goes
by the coach. This is hilarious.
They're actually showing them right
now, he's getting a, his gloves put on,
listen to this maniac
popped up.
I don't know you,
you're to hear that.
But basically you standing
there and he just goes like,
it's show time and then he just snaps.
It choked out and just, you got to,
I'm sorry, I don't even know if this
is even going to translate, but I got,
I got to get the rest of this shit here.
I got to get the other thing
that he fucking says here.
What the fuck is wrong with this stupid
piece of shit? Fucking God damn cable.
Anybody else have this fucking
problem with your cable?
All right now for this,
I'm going to make,
did I just delete it? You
fucking cunt. Alright. Whatever.
God Damn.
I thought I was going to be such that,
that was like my big fucking different
beginning that I was just going to have
there and I just ended up deleting
it because my fucking cables sucks.
Now what are you going to
do? It's a holiday, right?
I shouldn't even be doing this. So
anyway, so the next time they, they,
they come to him,
he's screaming some more.
So he goes out there and of course
he doesn't know how to fight.
He flailing or flailing around with
this dude. And in the end, you know,
he gets knocked on his ass and he,
and he loses. So it's, it's every,
basically, every time they show
the guy, he, he would say one,
the first little thing he would say
quietly and then he would just completely
flip out. I can't fucking believe I
got, I deleted that. What an asshole.
So whatever. The guy ends up losing in the
end of the fight, he goes, uh, he goes,
I'm ready for some more. I already
bleeding yet. And then he just snapped.
I buying yet.
Ah, fuck. I don't know what Co,
what sport that guy, coaches.
But if I was playing on his team,
I would run through a fucking
wall for that guy. You know,
I don't know all the pens. Depends
on your personality. You know,
I like maniacs like that. God dammit.
Why? I can't believe that. Fuck.
I knew that was going to happen. I
knew it was going to happen. You know,
it's the worst.
It was not on every bad enough.
If I had to try and rewind it and get
back to where the hell it was, but then I,
I, it comes up with a delete thing and
I accidentally deleted it. I'm sorry.
Everybody. Ah, fuck. Where the
hell do you go from here? Um,
it's Labor Day. What exactly are
you supposed to do on labor day?
Am I supposed to observe something
for all the people who died at work?
Do they have a little parade?
Do you guys like parades?
Those little pathetic things with the
mediocrely talented people of your town
marched down your fucking street.
There's not the worst when you come from
a small town. It's just a numbers game.
I mean, how many truly fucking
talented people can there be?
But somehow they still have to
put together a band. You know,
some chick with braces playing a
fucking flute marching down the street.
And then they always end it with like
a fire engine just trying to drown out
your bad local band.
We aim eh,
or everybody's singing in monotone.
A bunch of dentists and accountants
sitting there with their fucking weird ass
looking kids. God Ah, ah, ah, ah.
Do they do that today?
Is that what you're supposed to do?
Am I supposed to be dressed up
like it's the revolutionary war?
Reenacting something? I've
gotta be honest with you. Uh,
Labor Day feels like every other fucking
day to me because I'm a comedian and
I'm always sitting in my underwear
at fucking 12 noon. All right?
That's why I do this. Do you think I
want to make you fucking people laugh?
I don't,
I don't.
I just remember when I was 14 sitting in
my underwear eating toast one day on a
Saturday morning and I was thinking,
I want to be fucking great if I
could do this every day. You know,
wake up, watch cartoons,
wrestle with my fucking dog,
you know, and just have absolutely
no responsibility whatsoever.
And I gotta tell you something.
I made that dream come true.
We get worried when you die. God's
just going to be looking at the video,
your life,
you know,
just looking at it then kind of
glancing over at you and just,
just shaking his head. Haley, you
get one shot at this and this is,
this is what you did.
Do you realize that you spend over 98,000
hours of your life in your underwear?
And I'm not even counting when you were
fucking sleeping. Oh, speaking of that,
the other day I met him.
Still on, I'm still sorry.
Nia just walked by laughing at
me like I'm an idiot. I, um,
I'm still on European time.
Um,
today was the first day I actually got
up at nine o'clock. I've basically,
I have been when I was over in Sweden.
How did you feel about that?
When I was over in Sweden,
uh, last week, um, Clia,
what are you doing?
You stop walking around like a creep.
My dog is like most big
dogs there. Uh, she's at,
she doesn't realize how big she is and uh,
so she's,
but she's not afraid of a
lot of things. Uh, you know,
she's not afraid of other dogs, but
hardwood floors scare the shit out of her,
so she's so worried that
she's going to be slipping.
She walks like really slowly in daintily
all around the apartment and it looks
like she's going to like sneak up
on you or something. That's right.
Just laid out.
All right.
Woo.
Ooh, I got to teach her how to howl. Oh,
you guys want to see something
fucking adorable. Do you want to see?
You want to see something that we'll,
we'll,
we'll make you actually believe again in
whatever the fuck you stopped believing
in. Go on Youtube and search a boxer, B o,
x,
e r and baby and there's a little baby
playing with a boxer and I'm telling you
it's, it's, it's one of the most adorable
things you'll ever see. You know,
there would be less violence in the
world if everybody watched this video.
Actually that's not true. Everyone would
watch the video and then the second,
somebody next to you in, ah, yeah,
the rage would come back and you'd want
to just fucking blast him in the face.
But whatever. I digress. Let me get
back to what I was talking about. Um,
so anyways, so I have been when
I was over in speed and yeah,
I was up all night and uh,
and then I would sleep all day like
that awful heavy metal song by that band
slaughter and read that.
That's when you knew it was over.
Everybody said it was over when fucking
nirvana came out. No, it wasn't.
It was over when slaughter came out.
Slaughter,
slaughtered the rest of hair metal.
That awful guys voice
sleep.
No, it isn't right. It
isn't. It's fucking terrible.
Um, anyways, I'm plowing
ahead here. So, uh,
I finally got used to the time over in
Sweden and then I came back to the states
and now I'm on Sweden time.
So basically I have been up every fucking
night watching old football clips and
whatnot on uh, on the Internet and
I call it like, you guys all, uh,
sent me emails going, I swear to
good. I don't work for the NFL man.
Just tell me where I can see them.
Where do you see all the videos?
Where is the main site where
everybody watches videos?
That's where the fuck they are.
Okay.
It rhymes with Mu Lube. Um, anyways,
so I, that's what I've been doing
late at night. I've been watching, um,
these fucking videos and uh,
what am I trying to say here?
I don't know what happened. So yeah.
So I fall asleep at la about six,
six 30 in the morning.
I sleep until one in the afternoon.
That's what has been happening to me. I
feel like a fucking drug addict. Right.
So evidently yesterday,
um,
I was passed out and for some
reason I was in the nude.
All right, go ahead. Visualize that
one face down in the fucking nude.
And my girlfriend took a picture of me
because she thought it was funny and um,
I saw it and I,
I don't know,
I never really had a, Oh look, I never
thought it was a good looking guy,
but I thought it was all right.
I saw myself lay in there,
Butt ass naked and I got to met.
Dude, I look like a fucking cadaver.
That was the worst part. It's not that I
looked out of shape. I'm in decent shape.
I just look like somebody just
said fished me out of a river.
That's the only way I could describe it.
The only thing missing was bill
Curtis, his voice, just narrating.
I'm Bill Curtis,
a pasty frankly,
man was fished out of fuck
head river the other day,
this sleepy little town with their, with
the fuck. I was gonna say Memorial Day.
What the fuck is it? Labor,
the Labor Day parade. Hey,
stupid cunt with braces playing a flute.
It looks perfect.
And looking at me right now, go and you
do not sound like Bill Curtis, whatever.
I fucking looks.
I was dead.
So I deleted the picture and
then my girlfriend felt bad.
She goes,
I thought it was cute.
I didn't want to make yourself
coaches his on. It was cute.
It wasn't cute.
Yeah,
no one should see what they
look like face down naked.
I can't shake the image. I hope you
guys aren't having your fucking,
your traditional Labor Day
breakfast while not while you're,
you're visualizing then Jesus Christ.
I look at that Rosetta stone.
Remember I was going to
learn how to speak Spanish.
I just hate when you do
that and you're like,
I'm gonna learn how to do this shit.
And you and you buy something and you
stick it on your bookshelf and it's just
sitting there marking your
laziness for the next nine months.
I got that for Christmas last year and I
cannot fucking say anything in Spanish.
You don't really want to do.
I'm just gonna go down to home depot and
I'm going to find one of those Mexican
dudes who around always asking me if they
can fucking rewire my entire apartment
for fucking $3 because of the hardest,
hardest work fucking people on the planet.
Um,
and I'm just going to look at it.
Why don't I just give you 20 bucks and
teach you and you just teach me how to
speak Spanish. Is that okay? And then of
course it'd be like I had not died on.
Now I don't know what. Well, I know
I want, I want you to teach me,
teach Amelia how to speak a Idi,
done knowledge I'd done to leave saying I,
we just sit there for fucking an hour.
And then after while my forehead would
be sunburned and I would just give up,
that's probably what would happen.
And who knows,
maybe I would actually make a friend down
there and maybe he was really good at
an instrument and he
was slightly retarded.
And then I would draw that talent out.
And then some day a Freddie Prinze jr
would have a comeback play in that dude.
And we can make a little Oscar winning
movie. Maybe that could happen.
All right, let's plow ahead.
Let's, let's, let's get, let's,
let's actually be smart this week and
rather than waiting till 50 minutes into
this podcast to hype,
what the fuck I have to hype.
Why don't I hype what I have to
hype right fucking now. Okay,
well I'm going to do that.
And of course the second I sat at my
fucking computer shuts down. All right,
hang on a second. Um, all right. This week
I am going to be in Philadelphia, Penn,
Pennsylvania at the a helium
comedy club. Um, September 10th,
11th and 12th. Um, for the love of
God, please come out to that show.
Please show up.
And a,
I got a brand new hour at least
since the last time I'd been there,
cause I haven't been there in like a
year and a half and that's plenty of time
for me to come up with some new
shit. So, uh, please come down there.
I'm actually gonna try
to go to a Phillies game,
check out that new stadium and uh,
what else am I going to do there?
I think that's it. I think
that's it. You know what,
somebody actually sent me an email,
you know,
cause last week I was telling you guys
about how you can watch those Superbowls
clean out. Would you just
take a confidence step in
the apartment? Jesus Christ,
you would think there were
land mines under the floor.
The dog has never fallen down.
That's the funny thing.
I could see if she fell down the first
day she was here and then she'd have this
willingly. God, Oh my God,
she's never fallen down
and it was just pathetic to see a
scared pit bull, isn't it? Um, anyway,
so this guy actually told me about
a, uh, if you're into hockey,
hockey, I don't know, I just said
it that way for your to hockey. Um,
there's actually a fucking
website, if I can find it. Uh,
where I was watching the
1974 Stanley Cup finals,
like game six. I'd never seen it. Um,
and I was watching the Bruins verse the
flyers of course the flyers probably
when that fucking game, cause I know they
won the series and you have to go to,
uh, this is it right here. This
is for the sports fans out there.
It's h f boards,
B o a r d s.com/um,
actually,
you know what,
just go to that age boards.com and just
go to that and just start searching for
some games and they have all the
original games in their entirety.
And if you are a big sports fan like I am,
it's great to watch those because you can
watch how the game has changed and all
that type of stuff. I to be honest, man,
I had like the greatest fucking
weekend ever where, um, you know,
just because college football started
and I don't want to happen. Like two,
two years ago I became a college football
fucking maniac and absolutely love it.
And um, I was actually once
again sleeping until noon,
which is fucking like three
o'clock east coast time.
So I missed like most of the first
games I think. I think it was like miss,
like the first three quarters
of the first game. So I wake up,
my girl actually gives,
she would have made some breakfast.
She actually brings it into me.
I have breakfast in bed and I walked
into the living room after I eat it.
She just made me breakfast in
bed people. Okay. And I fucking,
and she goes into watch one of her
reality shows and I woke up and uh,
after I ate the breakfast, I realized that
I was missing all these college games.
So I just stumbled in the living
room because when you're my age,
you stumble for the first hour when you
wake up because for some reason your
Achilles shrink up to your fucking the
bottom of your ass and your legs don't
work. Right. Right. So I
stumbled in here and uh,
I just took the remote from our,
usually I say, honey deemed,
would you mind if I just kind of hung on?
I didn't,
I just fucking walked in and
I put on the USC game and uh,
she rightfully just looked down
at the floor. Like, really?
I just made you fucking steak and eggs
and you fucking just come wandering in
here. And then she just sort of walked
out and then I had to do that pathetic.
You know when you want to apologize
for something you just did,
but you want to continue
doing the thing that you're,
that you're apologizing for.
So rather than hitting pause,
I kept watching the game,
like yelling out the side of my
mouth as she was walking away.
Sorry honey ideas,
learning in [inaudible] and
I just continue to watch the game and
she gave me the silent treatment for the
next four hours,
which actually worked out good.
I think I watched like 12
football games this weekend.
I don't know why anybody gets the
fucking NFL package. You don't need it.
You can get all the, all the college
games you want for free and a,
and the kids are young.
They haven't blown out their knees.
They're fucking maniacs. Nobody's
holding out. I don't know.
I don't know what the fuck of saying,
you know it's getting hot in here cause
I have to close my goddamn windows cause
I curse too much when I do
this. You know what? I actually,
I have some more audio here.
Let me take a actually a sip of water.
Like I'm Frank Sinatra in
between fucking songs here.
That ain't water. Alright. Um,
you ever hear him say that he makes a
joke back then when it was funny that you
were drinking booze on stage?
Um,
I actually found another
record if you guys are actually
big fans of my podcast,
you know what sucks about this shit is
I have to literally move my mixer and
everything else listened to
it. Hit the floor, see that,
hear that. And then we go,
God damn these fucking wires.
Um, I've been slowly but,
and that's how you can never say I've
been slowly, you always have to say,
but surely you always said that they
take, they go together, you know,
sick and tired.
Slowly but surely suck my dick with my
balls. You know, it all goes together.
All right,
here we go.
I've been basically buying my dad's
record collection one album at a time and
this is one of the weirdest
fucking albums my dad had as a kid.
But because I was a kid and I
didn't know any better, I love that.
Listen to this shit.
This is basically the original like you
know when you watch Austin Powers and
their kind of mocking the
weird music of the 60s.
This is basically why this is a called
persuasive percussion 1966 and in defense
of the orchestra, I think that
they were trying to demonstrate um,
as many instruments as they possibly
could isolated how good they sound in the
new found high fi stereo. So
here we go. Listen to this shit
any day now.
Yeah.
Has that the shit or what?
Uh, you know, a lot of people,
if they saved they'd go back in a time
machine that they would go back and try
and stop Hitler.
I wouldn't,
I go back to this fucking
recording session because I
just want to see the looks
on people's faces when they
play that kind of music.
I always picture Barney Rubble's face,
you know,
when he was playing the drums in
that one Fred Flintstone episode,
we got Barney rubble Logan for trouble.
And he had like,
his eyes were all squinted.
Like that's,
I just picture all these guys and like
fucking those turtle necks with, with the,
uh, the peace sign. Remember how buddy
rich was, was dressing and like the, uh,
the early seventies when he was trying
to act like he was still going to stay
relevant with these new hip Kooky kids,
but he was still playing big band music
and he would come out with like these
plaid Johnny Carson fucking Hagar slacks,
a knitted turtleneck. And then you
on the outside of the Turtleneck, um,
a little precursor to Eddie Murphy's,
a pinky ring on the outside of his glove.
He would have his, he'd have his
necklace outside the turtleneck with a,
with a peace sign and it was
all in like silver, I dunno.
And he let his hair grow a little long.
Any of that awful fucking toupee pay out,
but he still was fucking fantastic.
All right.
Was that worth the trip all the
way over to my high fives stereo.
Do you guys have a hi Fi? Huh?
All right. Sorry about that.
I'm a fucking nerd. So that's basically
why I did all this weekend. I, uh,
listened to bad records and I,
I was listening to and watching all these
football games and I gotta admit you
got to watch these old football games
because it is such bullshit nowadays the
way they, they don't let these
fucking wide receivers can,
they can do whatever they want. You can't
even cover the fucking receivers. Huh?
Any Georgia bulldog fans out there. How
bad did you guys get fucked on that call?
I'm not saying that you
would've won the game,
but that was definitely
a pivotal fucking moment.
This guy is going over the middle, the
ball, his throne high and the defense,
the defensive back lays them out.
That's football and then like,
and Nancy scamming Gaffney and Yankee.
He where that roughness was unnecessary.
It was fucking pathetic.
I mean, unnecessary. I'm,
I'm doing my fucking job.
If you want to see how far football is
changed co I fuck it. Who gives a shit.
Go onto youtube and just fucking search.
Um,
search 1978 AFC championship
game, uh, Steelers versus
the Houston Oilers and watch part
four go all the way to the end.
You're going to see Mike. Barbara goes
over the middle. Dan, pastor Rainey,
the fucking douchebag throws it
like nine feet over his head.
But my Mike Barber is a Gamer,
right? So he goes up for the thing.
Mike Wagner comes in,
doesn't even look at the ball and just
fucking goes as low as he possibly can.
Hits Mike Barber right on his goddamn
nice. You ever see a guy on youtube?
You ever watch a guy like
slam into offense doing 80
miles an hour on a fucking
motorcycle. And that way,
you know, you just launch.
It's like you're standing up in the air,
but you're doing flips, head over heels.
That's what he did. He flipped
it, flipped around like twice,
landed on this astro turf and he's holding
his fucking knee and flipping out and
you know, he's on the ground for
like five minutes. When he gets up,
he's pointing and Mike, Mike
Wagner, you motherfucker,
you cheap motherfuckers
screaming all this stuff.
And the announcers in the booth of just
sitting there going like, well you know,
Mike wasn't looking at the ball. So, uh,
I mean I know I'm Mr Barbara is really,
he's really annoyed.
But I mean he was just doing his job.
He's just doing his job.
You know,
there was no unnecessary roughness.
Actually there was back then,
but you actually had to do
something that was unnecessary.
Now you're doing the necessary shit.
It is to cover a fucking receiver
and they go, it's unnecessary.
That's why one of the biggest bullshit
records ever broken was Dan Marino's
touchdown record by Peyton manning.
Remember that year when he cried because
the fucking patriots diff players
actually covered his fucking
receivers union with trying too hard.
And the next thing you know you can't
even touch these fucking guys and he
breaks Dan Marino's record Dan Marino
where to throw 90 touchdowns if you
couldn't touch Clayton and duper.
All right, that's it. I'm done.
I'm done with this sports this
week cause I know people are like,
oh you don't watch boring and didn't want,
and then when he telling him and they
get bored, well you know something.
Listen to another fucking podcast.
All right, you're whiny cunt.
Go enjoy your fucking Labor Day
on somebody else's podcast. Ah,
how do you like that? Look at me
getting all tough. All right, you got,
you guys want to,
um oh wait real quick.
Um,
my team is a Lsu.
I think I'm going to go with Lsu this
year is sound bought that les miles.
I just liked the guide fourth and 12,
two minutes into the game
and he fucking goes for it.
This is like a direct quote for him.
They go less.
Why do you always go for it on fourth
down? And he says, well, you know what,
when you have play makers on your team,
you have an obligation to turn them loose.
That might be one of the
greatest quotes ever.
And I love the southern
fucking turn them loose.
You got play makers on your
team, buddy. Okay, you follow me?
You have an obligation. Turn him
loose. Just turn him dogs loose.
Just see what to come up with.
Go out there.
Dig Up fucking first day on greatest
fucking fake field goal of all time.
Lsu. Look that up. Lsu fake field goal.
It's the smoothest shit
you're ever going to see.
Just flips it right over
his goddamn shoulder.
I was fucking them as a thing of beauty.
All right,
here's some youtube videos for you guys.
If you're new to my podcast,
this is what I do every week. I act like
a fucking moron in my apartment and um,
people send me in these youtube videos
already gave you the boxer baby one. Um,
and the Lsu fake field goal. And
uh, this is just a creepy one.
It's really quick, but it's
really creepy. Look up, um,
animal recording fail animal recording
fail at somebody's filming and Anaconda
or some big ass fucking snake. And
evidently this snake was not ready for,
it's a close up. Okay. We'll just leave
it at that and it will make you jump.
It'll fucking make you jump. All right,
this is going to be quick podcast.
I'm already to the questions,
you know,
I'm only 24 minutes and you
know what this feels like.
This feels like when I'm
fucking bombing on stage,
and I know a lot of you guys out there
and now comedians, sure, we all aren't.
And uh, basically what happens is
when you're having a great set,
all right, say you're slated
to do 50 minutes, okay?
Somebody comes back and they say,
Hey kid, can you give me 50 minutes?
Can you go out there and give
it the college track? Right?
And you fucking go out there and you
start killing. And if you're killing,
and if you're totally on,
what ends up happening is
you do 50 minutes and you
feel like you only did half
your act, you know, but on
nights when you're bombing,
you're about to jokes away
from your closing bit and
you look down at your watch
and you're about 12 minutes into your set.
And that's when the dry mouth
sets in and you're like, okay,
uh, so, uh, what do you
do for a living? Oh yeah,
here's my cute little jokes about
fucking plumbers, you know? Oh,
that's the worst I have to tell you about
to sound. My first headline in gigs,
this is basically how I became a
headliner was firstly I had to write the
material. All right. And
I had gotten up to a,
I knew I had 45 minutes,
but I had never done 45 minutes.
And when you headline or going last or
whatever the fuck you want to call it, um,
on a real show as a headliner,
you have to do at least 45 minutes.
That's how it works.
Okay.
I don't know where the fuck you
guys are from where I'm from.
That's how it fucking works.
You got to do 45 minutes.
So I've been doing standup for
about three and a half, four years.
So I had written 45 minutes of material,
but I had never done 45 minutes.
You know what I mean?
I was basically, at that point I was a,
I was the feature act of the second guy.
So I was doing like anywhere from 20
minutes to 30 minutes at the most.
Usually Feature Act does 20 to 25 30.
If you work at working with like an old
bitter headliner who's given into the
fact that he's not gonna make it, or maybe
he just doesn't feel like doing it. Um,
you know, that's when you work with
those guys and they just come up to you.
And that I work with this guy one time
and he looks at me and he goes, he goes,
hey, kid, kid. Uh, he goes, how much
time you got? I'm like, I don't know. Uh,
30, 35. And he just goes do all of it.
He's just like, do your whole
fucking act, play with the crowd.
I don't give a shit. I'll fucking do 11
minutes and close this show. I've had it.
Right. So, um, anyways, yeah.
So I'd written 45 minutes of material and
I, uh, but I never done it all in a row,
so I didn't know how to put it together.
So when I moved down in New York,
you know,
the only way to start headlining is at
some point you got to bite the bullet.
Just tell somebody that you're a
headliner. You don't tell that to a,
to a good room. You tell it to like, you
know, you have a rooms, you have be rooms,
you got C and d room, so like to c and d
rooms. I was like, I just told the guys,
yeah, I'm a headliner. And they're
looking at me, you know, I was just a kid.
They're like, you're a headliner. And I'm
like, yeah, yeah, my headliner. You know,
it's like when you try and get served,
when you're under age,
you just try to have that look
at confidence. Don't flinch.
Just give him the money. I would
like a vodka. Collins. Yes, I would.
Me and my one whisker on my chin
would like to have some alcohol.
Thank you very much. And um,
the first time I headlined,
I remember I went on after this, this, uh,
this black dude was on in front of me
and he was totally like high energy to
begin with. And, um,
that's one of the first things you
learn how to do as a headline is how to
follow somebody if they have
high fucking energy. Right?
So this guy's doing his act and you know,
it's like, it's, you know, he's
been doing it for a long time,
so he just keeps building with the energy
building and building and building.
And he ended his act doing some jokes
about like a prostate exam and by the end
he's just screaming.
Yeah.
And he's got his fucking,
thank God my mother fucker. Now
it's screaming into this, my killing in
this restaurant and I'm sitting there,
I'm already sweating trying to think how
the fuck am I going to follow that guy.
And I made the biggest fucking mistake
you can ever do is when somebody ends and
they're on 11 with the energy,
the worst fucking thing that you can do
is to go on stage and start your act at
the same energy that, that, that,
that guy left off. First of all,
you're not going to have enough energy.
There's way you can't be on
10 for 45 fucking minutes.
You're going to pass out.
Okay. And not only that,
it's bizarre to have someone
just come out on stage, you know,
please welcome bill burr
screaming.
I said, I like that guy in the tough man
thing. You know, you gotta get psyched.
You got to get pumped. I was coming
out with like that kind of energy.
So I went up there and eight
minutes in screaming my act,
I am pouring sweat and I remember looking
down at my watch feeling like I had
done at least 25 minutes and I had only
done like 11 minutes and I was out of
breath,
out of breath from telling fucking jokes.
And I had no,
I just remember there was a,
for some reason there was a big fish tank
in this place and I was trying to riff
about the fish tank and it was a
restaurant and like a, anybody oded,
the flay of fish goes, I think I know
where they got it. It was, it was awful.
Ugh. Just fucking, ah, I, you know
what, actually got a bad feeling,
just even thinking about that fucking set.
So if you are a comedian and you're
listening to this and you just starting to
headline,
if you follow somebody with energy,
what you actually want to do is
go in the opposite direction.
That's what I learned as you go up there
and you just start really fucking slow
and actually kinda eat your balls for,
you know,
just let everybody just bring it down.
Everybody fucking relax.
And then once you get them relaxed,
then you start to build them up again.
You know what I mean? It's just like
doing drugs. You start coming down,
but you know, once you go through the
floor and you start filling depression,
you take another drug and you
start coming back up again. That's,
that's where right there,
right as you go below the floor boards,
that's when I grabbed you by the back
of your fucking goddamn shirt and I pull
you back up again, comedically. And
then we, then we go back up again.
But this is what,
what ended up happening was I would do
my jokes and I could kill for 37 minutes.
And for some reason
when I said 37 minutes,
I just wrote it on my Ottoman
with my finger. I wrote 37,
like the fucking rain man,
fucking Weirdo.
I really have a lot of rain man qualities.
I don't know if you've noticed that,
but uh,
like
I can actually name all everybody who's
won the Superbowl the last 43 years and
now I don't have it in front of me,
but I can do it. So if you ever see me,
I'll fucking rattle them off,
rattle them off.
I'll have my head to the side
just like the fucking rain man.
And then if you want me to go
back and name all the losers,
I can fucking do that.
And uh,
I was actually at 1.1 to memorize where
all the Superbowls took place and that's
when, uh, right after I had that thought,
I kind of caught myself in a mirror
and I was just like, what are you doing
bill? What, what do, what do
you run it from? You know,
because I'm just sitting there in the
mirror going green bay, Green Bay jets,
chiefs, colts, cowboys,
dolphins, dolphins, Steelers,
Steelers. Yeah, Raiders,
cowboys. See, can I still do it? Steelers,
Steelers and then Jim Plunkett
with the fucking Raiders.
Joe Montana. That was
in Pontiac, Michigan.
They beat the Bengals and they stopped
Pete Johnson right down on the goal line
and then the fucking Redskins who I
hated because I was a huge cowboy fan.
They beat the dolphins. Does that Fulton
Walker? Huh? Took the kickoff back.
See,
I remember all this shit.
Then the Raiders kicked the shit out of
the Redskins and next year and then a
fucking 40 niners beat the dolphins.
Remember that sports illustrated with
Dan Marino was on the cover and he was
pointing at him like, yeah, this is
going to be the first one, right.
With Joe Montana. Next year was
the bears, which could have,
should have been the greatest
fucking super bowl ever. You know,
I'm just gone all sports this week.
I don't give a fuck.
I'm just going to give you guys
a heads up. Do you remember that?
The bears went 15 and one
in the regular season.
Okay. And the only team they lost to
was the dolphins on a Monday night.
It was fucking awesome cause the dolphins
basically defended the 72 dolphins,
you know, undefeated record
by beating the fucking bears.
So in the AFC championship game that year,
it was the dolphins first,
the Patriots, and we were
playing them in the orange bowl.
And we had this curse we had,
we had never won in the
orange bowl for like fucking,
I don't like 20 goddamn years.
Okay.
Since like Lyndon Johnson was an office
and the San Diego chargers played in Los
Angeles. Okay. And then, um,
the fucking dolphin should've beat us
and then they should have gone to the
Superbowl and then the bears should have
been set up to fucking avenge their one
loss of the year.
And then the dolphins with Dan Marino.
And that unbelievable fucking offense
was the only ones that was able to beat
the 46 defense.
And what fucking happens.
Stupid ass patriots. We come in
there and we beat them. Right.
And then, you know, with squish the fish,
remember that squished the fish and
everybody, Miami was just like, Ooh,
Dolphin join the foods. The removal. Hello
was some of the gay ass shit
talking ever 10 during that time.
And somebody had made a song in Boston. I
remember that song by Pete Townsend, uh,
face to face that face to face, get
to face to face, something like that.
Somebody wrote us a squished the
fish to that song, squish the fish,
get to squish the,
if it was fucking horrific,
but somehow I still actually watched
the game and then the Patriots got,
or they got raped, I believe is the best
way to describe it. Um, by the bears,
46 to 10.
Then the next year was the giants.
Then the Redskins than 40 niners 40
niners and then was the bill's era where
they lost to the giants,
Redskins, cowboys,
cowboys than the 40 niners
then the cowboys, then the
packers and then the pack.
Ah, yeah. The packers beat the
fucking patriots. I went to that game
than the Broncos won the next two.
Then the rams. Then the ravens,
stupid a that coach there. They have
no idea how fast we shut up your clown.
They beat the giants then patriots
than Tampa Patriots. Patriots, colts,
stealers. Giants stealers.
Huh? You like that Shit
fucking rain man.
What do you want to go to another sport?
Name another sport. I'll fucking do it.
I can go all the way back to
like the early 70. [inaudible].
That's what I actually fucking sit there
and I write that down on like Napkins,
cocktail napkins. When I'm on planes,
like that's how I make plane rides go by.
Like right now, maybe you're on
a plane listening to this ship.
I actually sit there. Green Bay, Green
Bay jets. Yeah, definitely the chiefs.
I know. I'm a fucking loser. All right,
let's get to some of the questions
here for the week. Jesus Christ near.
Okay.
This is what happens when
I'm doing my fucking podcast.
Nia is always getting ready
to go somewhere and she
comes out and all sorts of
fucking different dress.
Yeah.
And I'm not ready for it.
Um,
you just don't say you're going to go do
one of those sports illustrated covers
and why those ones where they wore the
mesh is bathing suit. Yeah, exactly.
All right. Let's [inaudible]
plow ahead here. Um, questions
of the week. All right,
question number one. Hey Bill, I'm sure
you've by now you've seen the punch.
Just wondering what your
opinion was on it. Personally,
I thought the Boise state player deserved
it and the expression on his face was
priceless. Go blue. All right.
There's a Michigan Fan are,
unless you're saying go blue
because of the fucking turf. MMM.
Um, okay. How do I explain this shit?
This is basically what happened.
Boise state played a, played Oregon
and I guess last year at Boise State,
um,
injured the quarterback on a fucking,
I was just picturing that
dude from England getting all
pissed. Listen, this shit,
cause I know he doesn't give
a fuck about all this stuff,
but I don't give a fuck.
But you don't watch this stuff.
I'll talk about the premier
league next week. So anyways,
somebody in Boise state injured
the quarterback a on Oregon.
So the running back on
Oregon said, uh, we,
we owe Boise state, uh, and ass
whooping. So he's basically talking shit.
So they play the game and they held that
guy who talks shit to minus five yard.
So at the end of the game they came up
and they talked a little bit of Shit.
The guy gets in his face,
it's probably like, oh, where
are you going to say now man,
what are you guys say now?
And then the dude looks away and the
dude who was getting yelled at just wound
up any fucking dropped
the guy and then it,
then it just got ugly and ugly and
ugly. What do I think about that? Um,
it was definitely funny.
There's definitely funny to see when you
received a guy getting somebodies face
talking to a bunch of Shit and
then the other guy just, you know,
just fucking winds up and drops him.
It was definitely funny, but, uh,
I thought that dude had a common, you
know, if you're going to say, you know,
you got an ass whooping common.
If you're going to talk shit and
then only get minus five yards,
you got understand that people are
going to give you some shit back. And a,
I gotta be honest, man, I feel real good,
bad for that guy because uh,
you know,
he could've got drafted and now he got
suspended and I'm just one of those heat
of the moment things were, I dunno,
it's at some point, you know, I mean,
he might've just fucked his whole life up.
Like now,
now he won't get drafted. And then
what do you do? You work at best buy,
you could have, you know, you could have
got at least, you know, even if you suck,
you're going to get like six figure
contract maybe for a couple of years.
You run around and play for the
fucking chiefs or some shit like that.
I don't know. It was just really
bad. It was fucking ugly and a,
and then the fact that it was a black
dude and he punches a white dude,
then you go on the internet and
everybody has to write some racist shit,
which is one of the things I really
can't stand about. Youtube is all the,
all the, uh, all the racist on there.
I really can't fucking stand that.
I don't mind when someone writes some
shit just to be a dick to annoy somebody.
But like a,
yeah,
the n word is used pretty liberally on
youtube. And that's the one fucking thing,
you know, somebody asked me that actually
about my website was saying like,
you know, why don't you have a
page where people can, you know,
leave comments and stuff like that.
And that's why I don't,
because people end up arguing and then
invariably somebody writes something
racist or something just really horrific,
uh,
something about Jews or something. And
then it's on my website, it's just, I,
you know, I don't condone that
shit and I just, you know,
I don't give a fuck what I do.
The podcast. Do you want to,
you want to write something or send it
to me and I'll fucking read it on this?
Um,
I don't know that I explained that I,
I feel bad for that guy.
I feel bad for that too because
he just fucked his life up.
And one moment by punching
the guy in the face.
But you're not saying I don't like,
I don't like when people
sucker punch somebody and
then they had like that. Yeah.
What, what fucking vibe?
What do you mean what, uh,
I wasn't looking at you when you
punched me in the face. Yeah,
I'm going to go down. That's really,
there's really no skill level there,
but in defense of that guy, if you do
get in somebody's face and talk shit,
yeah. You, what you do is
that you do that little,
you know that little gay backwards
skip that fucking football players do.
That's what you do. Why you look
at the person, you don't say, ah,
you don't talk shit and then just fucking
turn the other cheek like you're Jesus,
you know? Do you think Jesus ever
got dropped with that whole fucking a
wait, did he, did Jesus say that? Talk
Shit and then turn the other cheek.
He didn't say that.
He said if somebody slaps you,
turn the other cheek so they can slap
that side. What kind of a fucking,
you know, woe is me and that's
what, that's how I am not religious.
I can't get behind that son of God.
Not Son of God profit or whatever
that is is just some dumb shit.
Son.
If somebody kicks you in the left ball
when your eyes stop watering and you can
actually see your right ball, hold it
out for him so he can kick it. That one.
Yeah, go fuck yourself. You
fucking Hippie your stupid ass sandals.
He really was the original fucking dirty
ass hippie wasn't he wasn't Jesus that
all right. That should get some people
sending me some emails. God help me.
If I ever get fucking famous and they
start cutting up some of the Goddamn shit
on this podcast, I'm really going to be
in trouble. Um, all right, next question.
Bill. Did you ever, uh, at some
point in your early career,
think about performing on a cruise ship?
This guy has no idea how
funny this question is. Uh,
I'm not sure if you've ever taken a
cruise before, but let me tell you,
it's pretty fucking sweet.
Okay. He says, uh,
it seems like you literally a would
be getting paid to go on vacation,
get shit faced daily and flirt with
some finance trim in between all that.
If you could find the time on Tuesday
and Thursday night to do your act for an
hour in the main show room,
um,
not to mention you're waking up in some
of the sickest places in the Caribbean
every other day.
Let me know what you think.
All right? Um, okay. Amongst comedians,
you are never further out of
show business than when you do.
When you do stand up on a cruise ship.
Um,
people who do standup on cruise
ships, it's basically, uh,
I dunno,
it's,
it's like there's two places where
you go out to pasture as a performer.
Um,
Vegas and cruise ships.
Vegas isn't bad because you'll get like
$1 million, fuck me like that Danny Gans.
Dot. Guy would just fucking passed
away. Like that guy was making millions.
He had like, he was making
like five, 6 million a year.
He doesn't have to be on the road.
You let the crowd come to you.
There's a lot to say about that shit.
But, uh, when you're out on a cruise ship,
I mean, first of all, let's just
break this whole fucking thing down.
It seems like you'd literally be
getting paid to go on a vacation. Yeah.
Except you have to work.
That's actually one of the classic things
that club owners used to do when I was
starting out to try and fuck you over.
When they would try to book you down in
Florida in the wintertime and they'd all
feel like 80 bucks for the week or some
awful shit. And they'd be like, yeah,
but you know,
it's Kinda like you're on vacation.
It's kind of like a paid vacation.
Yeah.
Except I have to work except for that
working part. You fucking assholes.
Um, now, yeah, a cruise
ship is an absolute fucking
nightmare, believe it or not.
One of the first things you
want to do as a performer,
the second the show is over, is you want
to get the fuck away from the crowd.
You want to get away from
the crowd because the only
way to describe it is you,
you ever get stuck in an elevator with
some douche bag and you have to make this
small talk conversation that you don't
want to have imagined being stuck on a
boat with a fucking a
thousand of those people.
Cause that's basically what it is.
And I'm not trying to be unappreciative
of people who come out to see the
fucking show, but you know, I
dunno. What do you do for a living?
Okay, let's use the plumber
analogy. Does that guy,
I want to talk fixing fucking toilets.
How did you get into fixing toilet?
Do you get nervous right before
you have to fix the toilet?
You know, it's awful. I
did one cruise ship, right?
And I actually, uh, I got, I
didn't, I didn't get fired,
but I was definitely not asked back.
And, uh, the whole thing was alive.
They told me, I told him, first of all,
I said that my act is not
conducive to a cruise ship.
I just don't see myself doing well on
a cruise ship. And they were like, no,
you know,
cause people are old on cruise ships
and they're like, Nah, this
is a young hip cruise ship.
I already told this fucking story.
And I got on there,
there was that old
Vietnamese woman passed out,
missing all their fucking teeth up front.
And I ate my balls the entire weekend.
The only people I made laugh was the band,
you know,
the captain wrote a letter saying how
as offensive to all fucking people and
cruise ships are a nightmare,
sir. They're fucking nightmare.
And I don't know what cruise
ship that you're taking, but um,
all I know is that when
I took a cruise ship,
they would stop and you had basically
four hours to see whatever the fuck you
could see before you had to run back to
the ship or they would leave without you.
So it was a very stressful situation.
And then other than that,
you were just out on the water and
it all looked the fucking same to me.
Maybe I didn't take a good one.
I mean,
if I went to the Mediterranean
and did a European cruise,
I imagine that would be
cool. But, uh, you know,
I don't want to go to Athens
for fucking three hours,
you know,
and fucking sitting there running around
trying to see all this shit, you know,
in flip flops and a fucking
Hawaiian shirt, you know, dress like
Robin Williams before he does a goddamn
special. Um, it's, it's a nightmare Gig,
sir. They definitely pay well, but it
is, it's, it's a fucking nightmare.
And you're out to sea. And I
don't know, when I did them,
they didn't even have Internet access.
So there was no way for your fucking
agent to even get in contact with you if
you did have a big audition.
But even if he did have a big auditions
now you can fucking get off the boat,
you know, call a fucking helicopter
helicopter, you know, it's, it's horrific.
Anyways, let's plow ahead here. Um,
it's getting hot as fuck
here in my apartment because
I had to close the windows
because I curse. Um, what
is this section here?
Something I wasn't aware of. I don't
even know what this is. Let me read this.
Um, the reason I'm writing you is
I'm a huge college football fan,
but I have to say that there is one trend
that has emerged over the past decade
that really bugs the shit out of me.
Oh, this guy doesn't like the promos.
I haven't had anybody on any other
football fans, none of this. He said,
why is it that every major
football telecast kicks off
with some redneck singing,
a theme song?
I guess it started with Hank Williams
jr now that's the only one I know that I
read it on
Football Asia.
John not part.
Huh?
I fucking hate that. I don't like
that one either, but I wasn't aware.
He's saying they're doing it everywhere.
He said it's gotten way out of hand.
A few years ago,
college game day employed it's own country
music band to sing the show's theme.
It's like the guy with the fiddle.
Um,
and the guy wearing the big
top hat are supposed to be a little less
white trash because they're joined by a
black guy shouting out football
audibles in the middle of the song.
Wow. Dude, that sounds
fucking horrific. Um,
this year to top it all off,
all the day apparently isn't complete
unless some other Appalachian with a 10
gallon hat sings to the scene theme song
for ABC's game of the week on Saturday
night. Not to mention that
during the actual game,
the ACC has its own commercial with
some other hicks singing a theme song.
At least that is somewhat understandable
since the ACC is predominantly, um, uh,
southern.
Yeah.
Con Con Conference.
Such a moron.
All right. Ah, look, I get it.
College football has a lot of fans
in the southeast part of the country.
Football in general attracts
a large audience of white
males between the ages of
25 to 40. I am one of those
white males. And frankly,
I'm a little tired of my football viewing
experience becoming intruded on by an
assorted cast of characters from
Hazard County. Sorry for the ramp.
But I had to get that off my chest and
frankly my wife couldn't care less.
Oh Dude,
I'm in that boat.
I know that you start ranting to your
girlfriend about some shit and they just
start glazing over. Like, yeah,
I really don't care about sports.
So at any point,
if you want to stop yelling at me,
you're spitting on the side of my
face, by the way. Um, yeah, dude,
I gotta admit I haven't noticed that shit.
But I'll tell you why.
Cause I don't watch pregame or post game.
I don't, I just watched it. The Games,
I don't want to watch that part where
people like, you know, I'll tell Ya,
you know, if I'm Terry Bradshaw, I gotta
be taken. What's John Stallworth doing?
Fuck, I don't know. Give a shit, you know,
and I don't listen to sports talk radio.
All those people fucking freaking out,
losing their minds.
Give me an Oklahoma. We
launched, just joined
with the second stringer in relax.
That's why they have coaches.
You don't have to worry about it,
sir. The decisions will be made. Um,
all right. Underrated. Overrated
for the week. Uh, underrated.
The a television series,
brotherhood. Um, dude,
the Brotherhood was my show and
they actually cancelled it. Um,
this is what this guy has to say about,
he says a crime show on
showtime was recently canceled,
was much better than the similar.
The soprano's it had
superior writing and acting.
It also had a better place and his
characters were much more interesting. Um,
it could be just be that the whole Italian
mafia thing is getting tired genre,
but, um, but I got to go with Brotherhood
as overall being a better show,
although they were both good.
Uh, yeah, the Brotherhood is
awesome, man. If you guys,
uh, have a DVD store
around you, what sucks is,
is there's two awesome seasons and they're
really the cliffhanger that they left
you with.
It's basically based on the,
I think the Billy and Whitey Bulger thing
where back in Massachusetts they had a
really high ranking politician whose
brother was a really high ranking
gangster.
And uh,
this is something else I think I already
talked about on the podcast. Yeah.
That was like the dynamic and everyone
would always be asking the, uh,
was I think was it was Billy Billy Baldwin
or I think it was the politician and
Whitey was the gangster.
And they would always ask Billy be like,
what is your affiliation be?
I don't,
I don't have any affiliation with my
brother. You know, Massachusetts might
rather,
uh,
I'm just trying to do the best job I can
do to the tax payers of Massachusetts,
you know?
And the last thing I remembered happening
was the gangster actually won the
state lottery.
How fucking hilarious is that?
So this basically the show was based
on that took place in Providence,
Rhode Island. I highly, highly
fucking recommend that you watch it.
It sucks that there's only two seasons,
but um,
starts off a little slow.
There's a lot of fucking, uh,
there's a lot of characters,
but I'm actually at one point I'm
actually going to give away something.
This is just sort of a little vignette
that they had on the show is a Yankee fan,
comes into one of the provenance bars
and starts talking shit to one of the
hothead gangsters and who's a red sox fan.
And I'm a fucking blows his brains out.
And it was really,
it was disturbing.
It was disturbing.
Um,
so definitely checked out and that
fucking guy was a great actor and not to
mention that I'm the guy
who plays Freddy Cork,
um, is actually, believe it or not
because he's such a great fucking actor,
is Kevin Chapman who was a comedian that
I started out with and he was one of my
faith that was one of my favorite
characters on TV. Tony Vee was in it,
another great comedian from Boston.
I'm so fucking pissed that they canceled
that show cause, uh, that was my show,
man. I love that show. So I got to
go with you. Yeah, a brotherhood.
Definitely underrated. Alright. Overrated.
Uh, this dude says the black eyed peas,
the sheer amount of times I've heard the
new album against my will is staggering.
The only people you'll catch
listening to them are the lame ass.
Want to be cool white people who have
never heard of anything unless it was on
the radio. Yeah, I know. They
definitely play them in elevators.
And if you go to staples,
yeah.
Um, I can't even think of their
fucking music, but I can't stand. Ah,
did they do London Bridge always that,
that check when she went solo.
Oh, that was Fergie by herself.
Oh, that's right. I'm sorry. Yeah.
You know what I actually
discovered the other day? Uh,
I have a lot of shit in my iPod that
my girlfriend downloaded on her fucking
computer was on the blink. And
uh, did I say on the blink?
I didn't know what the fuck that means
when it was on the Fritz. He, uh,
so she downloaded all this shit
that I never would have listened to.
So the other day, what was that
song? Act Crazy. Who sings that song?
Yeah.
GNARLS Barkley. I never,
she used to listen to that
song and I fucking hated it.
Um, with that dude singing in
that falsetto, you know. Uh,
but I actually listened to the lyrics.
It's, I actually like the song now.
I was at the gym lifting weights,
listening to that song and I've
never felt gay or in my life. Uh,
I gotta wrap this up cause that was
embarrassing to even admit that. Um,
all right, I'm 53 minutes in. That's
going to be the podcast this week.
I know it's a little fucking, it was a
little off this week I think, but um,
I'm coming down off a Tylenol pm.
I had to do it to,
I had to drag myself up like fucking
Michael Jackson so I could actually fall
asleep by two at night so I could wake
up and actually try and do this thing at
some point remotely near Monday morning.
I hope you enjoyed this podcast this week.
I hope you guys had a great
Labor Day weekend. I apologize.
I can't believe I deleted that,
that rant at that boxer was doing,
it was fucking great.
The coach look out for him.
He's a tough man and evidently he's
ready for more cause he only started
bleeding. He, oh, started
bleeding. All right, that's it.
Please continue listening to
podcasts. I'm going to be at the, um,
helium comedy club this weekend
in Philadelphia, Pennsylvania.
Please come down to the show and
also, uh, please join my mailing list.
I never bring that up.
I would like to get more people on my
mailing list because my space is really
dying.
A slow pitiful death.
I barely get any emails over there
anymore and um, I don't know where.
I don't know where to go next. Um, cause
I imagine Facebook will take a nosedive.
Twitter,
we'll take a nose dive and his whole
jumping around is driving me fucking nuts.
I figured out how to blog here on my
website and I'm going to start blogging.
I actually began one about
Sweden that I will finish and um,
hopefully I'll get some
new videos up there,
but it's a bill bird.com if you
could go on and you sign up,
you just sign up for my
mailing list underneath the
city that you're closest to.
And basically I only send you emails if
I'm coming to your town or if I'm going
to be on TV.
I'm not going to be one of
these douchebags who every
week gives you the bill
burr update and then I become spam in
your life. It's not going to be that way,
but please sign up for it because my days
on my space might be numbered because
I don't, I don't, I don't know
that there's anybody left.
I'm really feeling like fucking Mad Max
and I'm there looking for fuel. You know,
it's just whores and uh,
people sell in music.
That's all that's left and me, you know,
tumbleweeds over there, people. All right,
that's it. That's the podcast for
this week. Please tune in next week.
Wait a second, wait a second. Did you
want to chime in with something new? Yeah.
Well.
I'm just surprised you didn't talk about
Tila Tequila shocked by that football
player.
Oh, that's right. Sean Merryman
choked out. Tila Tequila, you know I,
well, she's a warrior anyway.
She probably deserved it.
Exactly.
Fucking apple.
What do you mean it's a podcast?
I got to make it funny.
I don't like how you actually have my,
you actually have my voice
down like you actually know
what I'm going to say. No,
that's not what I was going to say.
I was going to say before I
so rudely interrupted with
your completely offensive,
I don't like how you know you,
have you noticed that with women,
whenever they do an impression of
their boyfriend, they always have to go
Ooh,
before they say anything. I wanted to go
out to go to a restaurant and you know,
my boyfriend said he was going
to take me and I was like,
so we're going to go to the
restaurant and he's all,
where's your football game?
I know my impression of you is really bad.
It is bad.
Do you want to go to a party this weekend?
My girlfriends,
Ben Roethlisberger wallet
that a while ago though.
What Ben Roethlisberger Ah, that
was, that was that, that was us.
That was a cash grab. He
raped me. Ben. Roethlisberger
well do you feel like, like the whole,
my whole big thing with the dogs.
Why don't you come over here near the
microphone if you're actually going to
come in here and high jacket. All right,
here's my lovely girlfriend, da everybody.
Hey, let me just do this as
like an interview, like a
little Dick Cavett thing.
But what was your question here?
Uh,
my question was in regards to
the football player who, uh,
allegedly choked out to what
Tequila, um, and, and other,
why are you being so official?
The question that I had this
afternoon and first of all,
I want to say I love the
show and I'm really like the
listener first time caller.
Uh, no, but do you think cause I
feel like, and I guess we'll see.
Please get to the point, man.
Oh well we'll see how the
story develops. But like,
do you feel like the Michael Vick thing
got more attention then when athletes
have like sort of like these abuse
charges, putting aside cost? First of all,
Sean Merryman didn't have like 40 my
space whores hung from trees that he was
electrocuted and drowning. Okay. He choked
out one dumb whore with a fake tits,
a bisexual hort that,
and I have to say that I fucking
hate the San Diego chargers,
but my hatred went down a
little bit knowing that he
slapped her on Tila Tequila.
That's just funny. If she was, if
she was just, you know, a regular,
you know, Girl from Hooters
whose dad didn't stick around.
So she felt the need to dress
around scantily clad and
try to get guys attention.
You want to see my clam? If she was one of
those people, that's a woman's Day. Huh?
Do you think that's a woman's
Day? Do you, I'll tell you this,
I'll tell you this right
now and I might get,
I might get in trouble here as I
weighed into these dangerous waters.
Women don't say clam,
they don't refer to it as a clam.
So how would you know that? Because
I'm a woman. You asshole. Well,
well first of all, oh,
you're storming out.
You're going to take off your
little lapel mic and just walk out.
All right. Obviously I know they don't
do that. Get back here. You can't,
you can't just leave like
that. No, they don't say,
I'm going to show you my clan, but I will
tell you this. When women get fake tits,
they will show you them like they got
the nails done because obviously it was a
very insecure part of their body.
So now they have it and they will eat.
It's so easy to even be able
to touch them. Then you just,
all you gotta do is like what their big
paranoia is. Now that they have them,
they want you to tell
them that they feel real.
So all you gotta do is just
be like, uh, you know other,
they look really natural at the,
do you feel like they feel oh yeah,
here and they just grabbed your hand
for some reason because their hand is on
your hand.
They don't feel like you're
actually filling them up
on Facebook before you felt
a fake boot before.
Okay.
The girl that I used to work with had
fake boobs and she was just talking about
it I guess like sometimes they do and I
was like, Oh really? And she was like,
yeah, feel them. They not read on.
Yeah. See where there you go guys.
Actually like Nice.
I haven't really felt a lot of,
oops. Well what you say?
Nice. What do they, what do
they felt like a bag of sand?
I guess both full and Nice and just
bucks to me and soft, you know,
like a woman.
Really? I can't even hear the
talk about, no, I'm actually,
I'm getting turned on by this. This is
like, this is really good. You know,
I got to tell you got a lot
of creeps or listen to this.
So they probably touching themselves
right now. I know they drive trucks.
I helped him out a little.
Now I'm not going to haul out my
girlfriend and my own podcast.
You're a good girl, right? Say it.
What do you, wait a minute. What are
you, this is what you do at the office.
You go around filling up
girls with fake tits. Where?
Where was it when you
were fucking in a bill?
Haley's swimming pool down the street.
I can never remember people's names.
What's the name of the fucking guy
who has playboy? Hector Camacho.
What's his name? Hugh
Hefner. I knew there was an h
nine oh, I'm brutal one. That's
the one on the on longer.
Hector Camacho is a boxer.
That's one of the,
the long standing jokes in
our relationship is how I,
this is what happens is I can never
remember famous people's names,
so I just,
whatever the first name that comes to
my mind or the names of movies like my
board, I called that movie the last days
of Dracula. What was the name of, Whoa,
what was that movie interview with the
Vampire? I called it the last days.
Last days of Dracula.
Ah,
that was a classic. We have a lot of fun
out here, don't we? It was at the gym.
All right, well we're gonna, we're
gonna wrap up the podcast. Look up cute.
Cleo was over there with the ears down.
Yeah, she's a cutie. All right. That's it.
That's it for the podcast. You got a
little bonus interview. Um, and that's it.
I want to thank once again.
Everybody came out in Sweden.
I'm definitely going to come back.
They're already talking about bringing
me back there and everybody in Philly.
I wrote a new hour. I'm going to be
there. Please sign up for my, uh, my, uh,
my website and a, yeah, if there's girls
out there with fake tits, I'm telling you,
you don't have to ask too many
questions and they'll find, you know,
this is actually a good
chance they'll take them out.
If you're in like a ground round,
one of those kinds of restaurants in
that restaurant where it was like,
I don't know how they
didn't shut down by the
health department with all those crushed
peanut shells on the floor. You know,
you walk into a barbershop,
they got to sweep up the hair.
How about you sweep up the peanuts?
You fucking disgusting. All right.
Have a good week. I'll talk
to you later. Bye. Bye.
[inaudible].
[inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].